The focus of five years of fighting in Syria: this is Aleppo.
And so is this, away from the rebel-held zones, at a pool not far from the battlefield,...
...they do their best to drown out the sounds of war.
Those relaxing in this government-controlled part of the divided city...
...can still hear the bombs and see the smoke, yet life and leisure goes on.
Shopping continues too.
We can't stop our lives from the people who are on the other side,...
...but we hope that they get a better life like we did.
Even children who've borne the brunt of this conflict can have fun...
...in a peaceful pocket next door to the apocalyptic scenes...
...that have made Aleppo a symbol of the horror, Syria and most of its people continue to endure.